this is gonna be a little bit weird but
I feel hey this is the only solution
a few days ago I streamed the choker Cup
my match against Rafael Santos of Brazil
and I made the terrible mistake of
forgetting to set up my audio beforehand
so the first few minutes of the stream
is muted so I thought what I would do is
kind of rewatch the beginning of the
stream offers some commentary and then
once once I did manage to turn back the
sound then that I'll leave it as is and
then people can get a full picture of of
what happened in the match
so anyway I'm gonna leave the video
playing but yeah for those confused this
is my my past self this is my present
self if you're watching this in the
future which is probably guaranteed both
of these are my past selves I don't want
to confuse you more so I should maybe
talk about what the details were for the
the match this is the the 20/20 choker
Cup it's a bracket format every Thursday
there is there's a match and this this
was the semi-finals
I played Rafael Santos who's a very
popular chess youtuber he has a very big
channel in in Portuguese and in the
first round of the trucker Cup he
defeated on a Rudolf so I knew going
into it that it was going to be tough
and we we play first two three clashes
which you'll see the clash score here
and this is the first clash I should
mention that this whole event is
sponsored by by toker
a little thing up here later on when I'm
not watching this on Twitch it should be
should be a bit more clear but anyway so
this is a first hand
I was out two pawns which is one of the
weakest starting hands
and maybe for those not familiar with
the rules every every game starts with
the betting face if we both call through
three rounds of betting then we move on
to the placement phase then after that
is the chess phase so this is actually
one of the weakest for kart hands two
pawns and two minor pieces so I went
ahead and folded and didn't want to risk
a large percentage of my chips and the
very beginning now there are cases where
they're special rules where there's
promotions or demotions which we will
see later and I'll share a link in the
video description of the full rules to
choker so this hand was was a little bit
better rook and pawn and my opponent at
first he checked and I wanted to play
aggressively I knew that if he checked
it was likely that he would have a
weekend I was assuming he had like pawn
pawn her pawn minor piece so I raised
and he folded so this turned out to be a
good play I'll also mention that there
was official commentary by International
Master Malcolm Payne and Jeff gross
who's a professional poker player I'll
link that below - it was on the chess 24
channel they they had both of our feeds
and were offering their their expert
analysis so this was another hand where
I was not so happy with I was a small
blind I didn't even want to mess with
with this I just folded so so far we at
least the first three hands we did not
make it out of the betting phase I think
this was a moment my chat was telling me
there were audio issues there was a
three minute delay so I was one of the
downsides that chat can alert me of
technical problems so I was trying to to
troubleshoot the audio while playing
here I'm dealt two pawns now the thing
about two pawns actually in the pauses
just to explain but if you're dealt a
third pawn
that's promoted to a rook if your delta
fourth-tallest
that's promoted to a queen so in general
if you're dealt two pawns you you would
like to see the next two cards and I was
a big blind here so the action was on my
opponent whether to call or raise or
fold my phone called
I was happy with that so I went ahead
and checked which is uh I think the best
play and I was dealt a third pawn so
that was promoted to a rook then I got a
knight as well and then I was deciding
whether to to check or bets now I'll
also explain just to pause again in
terms of valuing a hand I like to think
in terms of point value so pawns are
worth one point rook is five points 5
points and Knight is is three points so
this is a value of 13 which I think is
slightly above average wait did I do the
math right I didn't do the math right
this is a value of 10 which is probably
slightly average right however because I
have three pawns and a knight there's
another another special rule that if
you're if you're essentially dealt a
full house which is three of a kind plus
two of a kind
the third piece of three of the kind
gets promoted to a queen which actually
happened so I'll go ahead and show I did
check given that my hand is average and
then I got a knight so just to show
because I had two nights and three pawns
even though one was a promoted pawn the
3rd pawn gets promoted to a queen so I
know it's a little bit complicated but I
will share the rules if people want to
investigate so there was some
sound-effects
I think this is here yeah here this is
where I I fix audio so I think I'll
leave it at that
and and now you'll see you'll kind of
see what happens and
the placement phase and then the chess
phase the very first chess phase of the
match I hope you guys enjoy this if you
have questions feel free to comment
below and my next match will be a week
from from this Thursday so can I find
the date Alexa what's a week from this
Thursday here's what I found on weeks
Wikipedia page I continued a seven-day
cycle that runs through a history
without reference to the phases of the
Moon was first practiced in Judaism
dated to the sixth century BC had the
latest just changed something so it
should it should come through maybe in
like three minutes let's bet let's just
go all in
you can seem like a block okay this
probably determines the first clash yeah
I'm sorry about the audio issues but
hopefully if I put this on youtube the
the local recording should be okay
to do let's play f6
I should play defensively nighttime df8
or both oh yes two nights - that's
interesting
oh but he could yeah he could have a
very strong hand here um yeah I'll put
another D eights probably f7 in there or
f8 is next worst-case scenario he has a
queen which I can still like if he has a
queen I'm just down and rook if he has
another rook that's interesting
please don't have a queen please you
sound like a bishop or something okay
that's good so the Queen should be
relatively strong let's place it missile
on b7 idea Queen before Queen h4 ideas
board vision is very important
thanks for all the support guys I see it
anyway oh cool have a nice time
advantage a queen before she'd come he
could play rook g4 rook g4 maybe f5 like
the rooks aren't too powerful even
though he has a small battery I got five
and then I'll get some pawn chain I'm
trying to disconnect the rooks - hmm
wise move
to do this move I want to bring the
Knight to d6
it's a weird square but maybe e5
actually very important to keep the edge
on on the clock he came out sudden she
liked g4 also interesting blocking the
rook at some point like 96 he's six king
of seven the Queen before it's probably
not a great move she's gonna have some
checks quite seeing what to do
[Music]
yeah just preventing Queens here
let's play Queen before again so I could
play king f7 and be safe even like queen
bee one I'm not sure though try queen
bee one he checks me a few times it
should be okay
okay check oh wait what am i doing
losing focus let's try this moving way
too slowly
it's my threats
good position now
yes I'm winning do you want
let's start removing
no no oh man
got forts is it better now audio is
perfect okay good
oh that's so tilting huh I have more
chips I thought it was behind but maybe
not because he's big blinds I mean do I
call 2k I mean if he that's I guess I
have to yeah that was probably a bad you
guys should have raised I don't know
he's kind of weak on the great hand
let me still give me information though
he checks I have to UM have to shut up I
have like I guess I have an average
hands okay okay so I got two rooks two
pawns on the bishop he gives more chips
okay time is important and whites that's
a good thing
visually probably wants to be on the
dark square also maybe see two could be
interesting
okay very possible he has a queen yeah
let's be safe if he has a rook then I'm
just better if he has Queen and I'm
worse he's a bishop Wow okay so let's
learn my lesson from the previous game
time is relevance kind of allowing
Bishop c6 here Bishop c64 p8 um yeah
this should be a pretty routine win
because work a chain is also an idea
he just resigns
Wow opponent has yeah opponent doesn't
have enough to make the even a small run
so that's flash one to me okay I guess I
guess I'm happy so we take a two minute
break again apologies I know like what
the delay I can't address things in real
time apologies for the audio issues
earlier I did change the audio source on
my computer have to go back later and
see what happened so I'm gonna exit just
from this from what the app restarts so
let me update the score - oh okay I have
to take a deep breath man so reflecting
on that the the first clash I think I've
made maybe one bad bets but I feel good
about like getting a sense of how strong
or weak he is depending on whether he's
checking or betting
I think he's not being tricky in any way
in the betting phase which I think it's
probably best probably good to just
check the weekends and that the weekends
most often let me rename this
first man I should have won that one
game had the time advantage I was moving
way too slowly oh okay so it's the first
of three that's also something which I
guess it's important to note that should
be explained though yeah first of three
classes so that was a first class these
go by pretty quickly because the blinds
raise the blinds raised very rapidly
like we only start with ten we start
with ten big blinds and every every game
the blind increases by I think fifty
percent
I know it's increases by like five
hundred or something castling is legal
addressing a question probably from a
while ago but yeah if either side puts
the rook in the corner castling is legal
so there's not too many cases where it
will be relevant but it is I guess a
decent rule to to be aware of okay
oh we need to keep time ah so let's yeah
let's send another challenge
so the thing about Rafael he's very fast
which I guess I realized in this his
first clash I guess I learned a lesson
but didn't suffer suffer a loss in the
first class which is good okay I'm white
[Music]
okay I've not been getting the best
hands I'm just gonna fold when I fold
hands like this and then like when I
have stronger hands or just like when I
fold and then that later it'll make my
Beth seem stronger so it's important to
kind of understand how I'm representing
myself yeah I mean if he bets I just
fold I think he calls okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna check two pawns at some it
looks really weak but it can accept
remote is just something strong okay
beautiful um so this is like average
value actually he's 12 points if he
makes like a swell but I don't know I
think I should call I'm curious what
happens if I get another pawn if that
promotes to a queen no if I get uglier
pawn and then I it promotes to a queen
so odds of getting a queen Knight that's
like the worst card if he shoves like I
don't know what to do are you he's
definitely stronger
I think I just fold yeah because that
was just an average hand if he's shoving
there he's definitely above average I
think I'm better off okay so I have if I
double up then we're about on even terms
not sure if that was the best play but
may have been too conservative so I'm
basically pot committed I'm just going
to shove but I thought I think my
chances are better like here than
previously if I if I'd call that I don't
know though ooh
please Queen ooh-ah-ha if I got the
Queen that would have been amazing hands
so this is just yeah this is not a great
hand I'll probably employ a very safe
setup I'm probably gonna lose this
though you'll see what he has so I feel
like best-case scenario and probably
like down an exchange so the value of
this two plus six plus five that's
terrible
but he's playing me he's also playing
very safe was this bishop bishop is
usually not great on d8 helping in the
shadow now well he's playing very safe
so he could be weak um I worked with
playing really safe but if he has a
queen then I'm just dead which might be
the case
I'd likely resigned though enough to
gather as much time in this phase as
possible oh yes bishop okay um I mean
this is probably a scenario where I want
a castle I put my Bishop on a dark
spirit because my pawns are in light
squares complements uh the pawns better
he's had like a pawn oh here's a rope
okay so I'm only I'm down a piece for a
pawn just not grades but I'll try and
fight like if we trail off if I get the
pawns traded then maybe it's not so bad
um she came out I don't know King up to
you Rick h5 interesting score for the
rook
god I didn't blunder for some reason I
thought I allowed my Bishop before okay
so this is okay I think Bishop restrict
some nights you move my truck back so I
want to treat pawns I don't want to
trade minor pieces
rook is just dancing all over the board
rook is now active and preventing Bishop
e5 though which is nice
provoking Bishop c6 they just move back
let's play rugby six Bishop c4 coming
it's not pleasant
yeah let's trade rooks not what I wanted
but sometimes you got to do what you got
to do
he doesn't trade interesting probably
good move
I'm just chilling okay this is what I
needed I don't know if I'm there
specially six unfortunately please miss
it yeah probably have to take and then
like see three shaking shaking off one
first just to prevent trades oh this is
just pure torture thing is I can move
around and make him prove something okay
this is what I want it's not plunger
94 attacking the pawn gypsy - coming
every gypsy 7 let's go
winning the pawn it's gonna come down to
time though like now I'm just going I'm
going for the win going for the flag not
good to allow that's not good to allow
dirty flag let's go
ok if I can win that then I that gives
me confidence well the game ok so it
paid off paid off
I'm the chip leader blinds are
increasing a lot of time yeah
so I'm big blind oh that's why I like to
see if he yeah we'll see what he wants
to do if he calls and I probably should
okay folds that's a lot of chips oh I
guess I just wanted 1.5 K but it's still
good some whites I'm gonna be small
blinds fines increasing so much yeah -
case small blind that's crazy I think I
just shot here statistically he hasn't
equal or worse hands so hey let's go
let's go ok good hands very much above
average
it's a valium not using nineteen average
is 15 so I mean I always have to be
prepared for the worst-case scenario
I'm sticking with a setup
you guys should mix it up being very
predictable but I guess this is a safe
setup so worst-case scenario I'm not
like losing oh that was that the demoted
pawn I think that was a demoted pawn put
the rook here interesting yeah I'm just
gonna chill with the bishop again like
spawns on light squares Bishop under X
square there's a good combination and
now for the majesty and coming on a two
looks decent have the nice long diagonal
access to g8 and eight
he has a queen - okay so I'm only up the
exchange not a bad situation just a
castle Knights are tricky I do have I
have some like holes on the dark spirit
is what the bishop helps remedy that
playbook anyone gonna have to be
conscientious of time Queen a8 and Queen
824 looks decent I think that Bishop
wants to be on III so this late on a
fade is very restricted basically tied
down to h7 if Knight c5 I might just
take it please my e5 ok so there's some
work see one idea Bishop h6 ideas rugby
seven ideas - Brooke c1 be very tricky
or very careful of the tricky Knights
this move important to identify the
weaknesses e7 is very much potential
weakness I think I want to play f4
decent-looking idea some coin in one
check I've kingi to interesting that
defends its throw-in a check I have to
save the bishop did this move
I just want to trade off Bishop for
Knights
I'm also preventing Queen e1 now times
about equal
25:25 then i have on 0.5 friend ze one
to probably Rexy one there are thinking
okay seven it's maybe playable but
Kirksey ones probably safest this Queen
d2 could becoming Queen III okay so I
have on this looks pretty simple and
then I just want to take the Knights and
then probably simplify rook e1 to just
tickling the Queen
looks promising but I don't think it's
completely winning nuts nice on
advantage h5
so I have Queen III that's okay though
oh no I blundered I've laundering log 27
okay he misses it that's good GG -
that's why boardvision so important have
to remain non flustered this meeting so
close to me okay this is meaning so I
could have very easy lost out if he
played Queen 87 why win the clash
opponent has been sufficient funds to
zero okay so I'm making up for for
everything in the chess phase I'll exit
Alexa so the timer for two minutes two
minutes starting now okay okay so it's
it's two to zero
I just need to win one more clash I'll
see if Rafael wants to accepts or wants
a longer Rick won't blame them if the
break should be longer okay we're
starting good luck okay it looks like
I'm live too which is good
okay stay focused I think I just fold
right yeah if I'm small blind
I fold we streamed my streams coming
through okay beautiful okay I'm black
and blind so the fact that I won the
first two clashes shouldn't affect
anything in the play style another
suboptimal hand if he raises he calls
okay so I check this is pretty routine
approach it gets your two queens I know
this is still a decent hand um I think
I'll make like a pot that's actually
well let's see what he wants to do is
very small bet if he call us and he's
and then I'm probably stronger than him
well I got a third pawn
cuz it was a demoted pawn uh probably
checking I don't know though wow this is
the same situation I was in before I
think I fold right it's uh it's mine
that's I have below average hand after
fold
I was yeah my mind after the fourth card
was in the state I should have checked
there's high profitability I was getting
a pawn now the goods great starts okay
so this is where like if I have any good
hand I'm probably gonna have to shove I
mean let's shove I have some told that
Cody a good okay okay that's what I like
to see oh that's what I like to see
night night night neck okay that's okay
a knight would have promoted to another
queen because it would have been like
what's it called the palace so this is a
better-than-average hand and because he
he called the all-in after two cards
statistically I should in most cases
have a better better hand that we'll see
always have to think worst-case scenario
moving very quickly so I'm sticking with
the same setup it's worked in the past
he's playing safe it's a queen it's a
queen here it's my square I'm very
similar to to last time I'm trying to
provoke something to be placed on beings
might not be the case but if you places
something on beer that I can place a
bishop on a two places on see that's the
best play
so if he has a queen and that's equal
okay so I know he's gonna be threatening
rook c1 so I planned this to Castle the
first move is a queen Swit sequel yeah
let's just castle okay Knight is
probably better than bishop because the
pawns are clustered in one general area
even though it's an open position not
entirely sure
going for the Queen shade because rook
plus bishop should still be better than
your ax plus Knights that's really just
equal it's gonna come down to time salon
Queen g6 King f8 Bishop e3 I think that
was a huge funder by him because King
yeah King D I'd work on eventual work c1
let's not get too confident I do like my
chances Bishop h6 coming ninety-seven
still Bishop h6 yeah like he can't even
take on me - because Bishop h6 is force
meets now there's no there's no escape
for the Kings upon Cameron this is
reasonable okay so this worked out oh oh
but I take and he's gonna play 27 tricky
tricky oh but I'm gonna have rook h1 and
end so Queen a 17 g2 takes g5 rook H one
and it should still be first mate
h1
oh yes Queen oh this is tricky
I should start with this the queen g4
it's not over
Oh queen g4 tricky g7 and Queen f6 I
traded in Rakesh a-ok
a pawn line simple line though it's just
just about being persistent with going
as deep as possible yeah
so initially I saw Queen D for
preventing or key chains that's a free
Queen he saw he saw this corner to this
corner but not this corner to this
corner important vision I find the chip
leader again so this is nice I've been
winning it's like the equal positions
[Music]
sound big blind okay
ooh okay so still a good hand and the
fact I got two queens is it's very
unlikely he has a queen uh yeah so he
limps I think I just shove them all in
he's blocking me that I believe if he
folds and one thing was a bad buddy okay
so this could be the last game very good
hands
average value nineteen come on I only
have one pawn to that's Mike moves first
okay so I want to be safe because I'm
black to be careful two pawns that's
good very good sign I don't want to take
any risk here I want to keep the time
advantage
it really knew no reasons I think too
much so if he checks me on the square
like a four or H five I guess possibly
and then either night can block I guess
Bishop f7 worst-case scenario he has a
queen and I'm just up the piece up a
piece for a pawn we had the situation
actually we use a rook will be beautiful
okay let's just stay focused no need to
celebrate just have to play good moves
keep the time advantage pray for no
disconnection have to be careful of the
Knights I just want to simplify though
it's the best approach maybe four I mean
either simplify or just attack yeah I
mean I guess I'm going for the attack
listen is actually has no squares
that's incredible oh that's the moves oh
good
like Queen each six I'll keep the pin
and I'd still restricted out and has to
retreat and then some Knight to e5 I
didn't like g4 I do i I do have less
time but I have plenty of time
I should keep the pace
I'm the chief or it's very hard to stop
forgot about that move
well I've quit for back there okay Jade
never hurts me
Knights are very clumsy expecting the
gf1 and now this move along work age for
you can be resourceful thanks for the
bits
kingi one I probably never mind yeah so
let's just simplify I'm nervous I
shouldn't be nervous so good position up
on time mm-hmm let's move
wanna play Queenie for soon it's
attached likes very restricted to rock
f3 I just take the leg with Chuck thanks
again for the pic I thought I turned off
the their thoughts I guess not the kind
simplifying completely yeah so the pawns
work very well with them on their pieces
just a control I'm doing well laughing
keep up the great content thanks so much
I appreciate that
I play off three always play off three
just have to be care
not to stalemate okay now it's probably
time to celebrates that was yeah that
was much much closer than the first
match but I feel like I feel like I made
most for the right decisions okay so I
should I should get ready for the
interview okay so what's going to happen
I'm just waiting to start the interview
with International Master Malcolm Payne
he was doing commentary with
professional poker player Jeff gross on
the chess 24 channel so I'm I assume
maybe some people we're watching both
also shout out to my opponent Raphael
was also doing commentary on his YouTube
channel he is probably I would imagine
the biggest chess channel of Brazil or
biggest chess channel in Portuguese I'm
not aware of any actually not aware of
any other Portuguese youtubers that talk
about chess so if you speak Portuguese
or want some gas and contents in
Portuguese
check him out I'm not the Magnus of
choker
if anyone's a Magnus of choker it's
Hikaru for maybe Magnus I don't know if
Magnus plays poker or choker I feel like
Magnus would be really good at this sort
of game though like understanding the
odds but hello so I'm looking at myself
shall I look at him rather yeah I am
doing okay I can see Erik hey Malcolm
can you hear me yeah I can hear you Erik
congratulations thanks so much yeah that
was okay
are we live or not yet okay not yet got
it
we're actually we're live on my twitch
channel so I took taken without without
live from on the official choker stream
as well okay great so congratulations
Eric very very smoothly done I felt on
the end in the chessboard your superior
tactical skill it made its appearance
yeah I mean first of all it was
definitely a lot tougher than my first
match I think my Raphael definitely
understood some some deeper like I think
strategy yeah and yeah yeah and like my
first match I just got really good cards
like the the first kind of round of each
of each clash I was just getting amazing
cards here there there are a lot of
hands that kind of had to fold and and
be patient for when I I got something
yeah we know there are a lot more folds
in this much actually than any of the
other matches you see so in your first
match against Simon he he was all-in
most of the time and we felt you
exploited that really well but there was
a lot more finesse in this match and you
had to be patient sometimes right yeah
for sure I mean of course I watched
Rafael's first match and I tried to get
a sense of his his kind of range with
bedding and I mean he has a very similar
range to me where he need like folds or
limps with weekends like pawn pawn or
pawn minor piece and in just plays very
aggressively with much higher value
hands so yes I knew that going into this
match and I can kind of sense like if he
was checking then at the very least I
shouldn't be worse right I also noticed
a strategy that you use that no one else
did he I think you're the first person
to actually castle in and choke a
Challenge Cup so that was a real shock
in fact I suddenly saw though what
happened there yeah I like I was not
aware of that when I first started
playing and then I think at some point I
just wanted to experiment see if it's
possible
and I guess technically like the king
and the rook haven't moved yet because
they're just on their starting squares
absolutely I mean they've made it out of
a pack of cards onto the board but it
doesn't constitute a chess move right
exactly yeah I don't think it's like too
often that it makes sense to castle but
when you want to play safe and it's not
a ballad should have yeah I mean when
you have the pawns on E to F 3 and G 4
it looked like quite a good setup so you
kind of have the dog squared Bishop
swimming within the Whitehead pawn chain
and it's kinda like the white squares
covered by the porns dogs but covered by
the bishop and felt like felt totally
safe actually certainly worked out quite
well yeah I was explaining that on on my
stream that you want to make sure your
Bishop harmonizes with the pawns well
yes yes it's interesting that a bit of
positional chess what we call in chess
good bishop and bad bishop comes it
comes into play that actually beginners
in chess often think that you want to
have a bishop that's the same colors
working on the same colored square as
your pawns mm-hmm because it can protect
them but actually those pawns inhibit
its mobility right so we prefer to have
the bishop of operating on opposite
color what did you what did you make it
what do you make of the of the setup at
the beginning and choke with two Knights
defending each other how do you feel
about that it that's that's made a lot
of appearances particularly when one
side has less material at the beginning
so you mean like superfluous Knights
like just nice or are Knights defending
the King I would say if you're if you've
got less material or you've got a fairly
weak hand you kind of put nights on d8 +
f7 or something like that that seems
trader strategy that quite a few people
have used yeah yeah definitely I think I
mean a knight next to the king is one of
the best defensive mechanisms in open
positions yes and 9 games especially
when Queens are on the board and use
that I think in one of the games we had
an island f8
King on f7 it was very hard after I
clean sir infiltrates that's right well
I think it was saying on a stream that
been lost and once sent with a knight on
my fate it can't be mate that doesn't
doesn't necessarily seem to be true in
shoka all of the time as you
demonstrated there was one game that
seemed real interesting word I thought
it was just going to come down to the
clock because absolutely nothing was
happening
and there it just seemed to me that the
best kind of moves were just the moves
any move that you could play real quick
it was just the best move really it was
it was quite weird yeah I think that was
a game where I was just down like a
minor piece for a pong exactly man yes
yeah the strategy's just to survive and
not basically not trade minor pieces but
trade pawns yes and of course for his
and I wanted to keep at least one pawn
on the board for for a sufficient
meeting material for the flag indeed I
think he had a chance didn't he that
when he was up a knight in one game and
he should have just removed your two
palms when he was running out of time
and then he would have he would have got
a drawer I think in in one game but he
ended up losing on time I think yeah I
think I know what you're talking about
it I guess he made up for it the I mean
the first game well before I think he
was amazing flagging and losing on the
board and he forced me and took my that
was impressive because yeah the amazing
thing I mean kudos to Rafael Santos mr.
chess in Brazil because he doesn't
actually have an official rating I asked
him before and send him a message of
what is your official rating because
trying to find someone's bday rating
when their name is Santos is a bit of a
struggle that's true and I just wondered
if he if he had a rating but she know he
doesn't have a chess rating at all so I
she's an immensely talented immensely
talented I think that which is
incredible yeah I mean I knew I knew
he's a strong player like he yell played
out of rudolph in the first round and I
did look him up on chess calm and I
think he's it's around like twenty to
twenty three hundred and blitz
so I knew it was definitely gonna be a
challenge great so well you're in the
final I guess because we know you're
very methodical you told us in advance
in your in your pre-tournament interview
that you prepared for every opponent so
I'm sure you'll be watching the next
broadcasts at the same time next
Thursday and 11th of June got Fischer
Hogan's against Alexandra botas so
international master Eric Rosen
congratulations you're in the you're in
the choker Challenge Cup final thanks
very much yeah looking forward to it
take care alright and a reminder to
everyone get involved with Joker
download the game it's free to play from
the Apple Store or Google Play
thanks very much everyone
okay I'm gonna leave the call I don't
know if you can still hear me but uh I
can't throw it worth it okay thanks okay
bye-bye okay um I think there's still a
stream delay but I'm going to let it
actually what's the best approach here
I'm gonna end the stream now and then
send the rain once once I do you like
the sign-off I have to get the timing
down anyway thanks everyone for watching
I appreciate it hope you guys enjoyed it
I'll be posting the whole thing on
YouTube at some points and yeah goodbye